Mrs.
Merkel,
I agree with them,
with all the harshness of the rule of law
we must crack down
against manslaughter,
against the murders,
which are now on our streets
play.
If you are in the wrong place in Germany
at the wrong time is,
1 can get it,
too.
And on legal certainty and the rule of law
must also belong to it,
that Joseph A.
The alleged Iraqi election
subsequently it has turned out,
that all his documents were forged.
We are talking about the murderer I say murderer,
not manslayer hm hm from Chemnitz,
that he entered without permission,
has committed several offenses
and his asylum application was rejected.
By the way,
this is not an isolated case with them,
but it is the rule,
that they are responsible for as government.
You, Mrs.
Merkel,
are to the greatest safety risk
become in this country.